hey we are are you i think i'm run
jonathan truthin where the property
brothers were at BuzzFeed and we're
gonna read some tweets so who's sending
these are from your biggest fans
something about the property brothers
ripping out a kitchen countertop makes
me horny
well why do you think the radio hi slow
motion renovations in tight jeans but
it's all that said him what do you want
from others day me fantasizes for
several minutes about threesome with the
property brothers flowers would be nice
ok you should check the Cameo we did on
playing house on a USA Network that's
exactly what that scene was all of it
pretty much and by the way Jonathan
wanted to be a flower man when he was
young so it's kind of the same thing I
want to marry one of the property
brothers or both of them if they'd be
into that that is actually the that the
biggest tweet Jonathan probably gets is
will you marry me or drew I'll take
either whichever one works I'm fine I
just want to be the meat in a property
brothers sandwich is that so much to ask
who are you perverts like it depends are
you wait are you guys I'm married now so
called call him are you processed meet
the property brothers have nice butts
I'm glad so most people say have nice
butts look we are two people yeah we
have different but we don't share an ass
we're twins we share brains it's not a
but not reading that one I'm ready to
stop hiding my emotions
stop sheltering the world from how I
feel inside my heart I'm ready to
finally say it the property brothers are
dumb sexy is that like cool like young
hip lingo
oh they're lit their dumb sexy I don't
know dumb it's one of them's dumb and
one of them sexy they're for you I want
the property brothers on HGTV to double
team wolf I'm not reading the rest of
that one that's fine moving on the
property brothers tune
I like to think that this is like a
nine-year-old dude I kind of think what
we need to do is create like a body
pillow
with our faces on it I think that'll be
then you can take the bros home you just
broke theater it would be two separate
pillows so otherwise it's creepy the
property brothers can destroy and try to
sell me any day well we don't just
renovate houses the property brothers
are so effing hot I want them both just
mmm and there's a bunch of emojis and a
smiley face like a licking day night
star I spend every episode of property
brothers trying to decide which one is
more attractive duh he's had work done
this is I I just really wanted to look
like Jonathan yeah do you want a guy who
man escapes or do you want a guy who
well it's not gonna have sorry and just
II know I know where I was going with
that
every time someone swears say unicorn I
want to unicorn have unicorn passionate
relations with the property brothers
while they talk dirty to me about house
renovations that's just a typical day of
filming for property brothers said it
before I'll say it again property
brothers can tag females that caught
that that sort of rushed up on me there
every time I watched property brothers I
get a so I don't watch property brothers
anymore
hashtag HTTP are you really part of the
HDTV community if you don't want to have
relations with the property brothers
no you know
no that's why on our cruise sailing with
the Scots every night I sleep in a
different captain is now hashtag twin
sandwich one of the property brothers
just said open these walls up and my
legs automatically pull over my head
well I think that's a great one to rap
baby baby me so thank you very curvy
tweets out there and watch papi brothers
and go to kasa.com by the way cuz saza
is where we have all of our design
inspiration for you
does the plaid shirt match the underwear
you'll have to go to kasa.com to find
out you're all a bunch of pervs does
your mother know you tweet these things
[Music]